الغردقه او قرش الغردقه عنوان من الخميس
على المنصات والسبب حادثه السائح الروسي
اللي انهت حياته سمكه قرش هو بيسبح في احد
الشواطئ هناك السائح كان بيصبح على بعد
عشره امتار عن الشاطئ وهاجمته سمكه قرش من
نوع قرش النمرته لها اربعه امتار ووزنها
900 كيلو وانهت حياته ووزاره البيئه
المصريه فورا ارسلت فريق لسيد سمكه القرش
اللي هاجمت الشاب وقالت في بيان انه تمكن
الفريق من الصيداها وتم نقلها للمعمل
لفحصه وجمع المعلومات المطلوبه لتحديد
اسباب الهجوم وقالت انه راح تصدر بيان بعد
ما تنتهي من اعمال فحص القرش باغلاق
الشواطئ لغايه ما تتم عمليات المسح
والتاكد انه المكان في غيره الفيديو طبعا
كان قاسي جدا جدا وما حنقدر نعرضه لكم باي
شكل لكن من وقت القصه واحنا شايفين بوستات
وفيديوهات وتع ليقات فيها تساؤلات عن كيف
ممكن الواحد يتعامل مع القرش ونصائح
وتعليمات ايش الواحد لازم يسوي ومعلومات
عن القرش يهاجم ومتلقى كميه معلومات
وتعليقات مو طبيعيه يعني وكثير منا حتى
كان متضارب يعني فقلنا يعني انه خلينا
نسمع من مختص والسيد حسن الطيب مؤسس جمعيه
الانقاذ البحري وحمايه البيئه واللي عنده
اكثر من اربعين سنه خبره في المجال جاوبنا
على هذه الاسئله خلينا نسمع
عايز اقول بس رايي كده في قصه هجمات اسماك
القرش بالنسبه للغواصين ما فيش اي قلق على
الغواص نهائي لان الغواصين بيجوا من
الخارج مخصوص عشان يتفرجوا على اسماك
القرش ويشوفوا السمك القرش زي ما بيشوفوا
فده بيبقى متعب بالنسبه له ما فيش اي
خطوره عليهم لان بيبقى نازل زيه زي القرش
سمكه لبس الغطس فما فيش مشاكل عليه نهايه
اما السباح والسنوركينج واللي بيعوم على
السطح ده لربما يكون في موقف اضعف من
الغطاس بكتيره قوي سمكه القرش دايما بتبص
للي فوق على السباحه اما تحت الميه عمرها
ما بتهاجم الا نادرا يعني نادرا لما
بتهاجم سمكه غواص اما بخصوص السباحه اللي
بيحب ينزل يسبح في الميه طبعا طول ما
بيكون في مجموعات مع بعض القرش زكي جدا
اسماك القرش زكيه ومش بتهاجم مجموعات
عمرنا ما شفناها دخلت على مجموعه الهاجمه
دايما بتعمل مناورات مناورات حتى في
الحادث اللي حصل في الغردقه عادل القرش ده
يعمل مناورات كتيره كان فيه اربعه خمسه
حواليه لما الاربعه خرجوا للبر حد من
الروس السياح كان بيقول قرش قرش اكولا
بينصح الناس يطلعوا اطلعوا في اربعه
استجابوا وطلعوا ما عدا الشاب ده الروسي
ما خرجش وما طلعش فهو كان بالنسبه للقرش
يعني صيد سمين واحد لوحده فقدر يتهجم عليه
ويجيبه فاحنا بنقول للناس دايما اما
بيبقوا في مجموعات
ويستمتعوا بالسباحه مع بعض ما فيش اي
مشاكل عليهم نهائي اما بالنسبه للناس اللي
بتفتي كل واحد له راي يقوله لكن هو ده
المتبع عندنا في مجال الغوص بصفه عامه كل
الدنيا بتيجي الغواصين
وبنسوق سمكه القرش تعال علشان تشوف سمك
قرش عندنا في البحر الاحمر الغواصين وبيضر
دخل قومي للبلد بيدعم
السياحه فوجود سمكه القرش ضروره ليست فقط
للبيئه البحريه
بل ايضا للسياحه دعم للسياحه فوجوده ضروري
جدا في البيئه البحريه